recently uh you acknowledged that you
were working on a Star Wars film a
number of years ago and I'm just curious
how close did you actually come to being
in the director's chair helming a Star
Wars film well I believe a movie is
going to happen when the Blu rid comes
out that's that's when I know it's going
to happen you know so it it always in
the last moment things go away I've had
it happen many many many times um we had
uh the rise and fall of Jabba thead so I
I was super happy we were doing a lot of
stuff we were and then uh you know it's
not my property it's not my money it's
one of those 30 screen place that goes
away you know and I sometimes I'm bitter
sometimes I'm not I always turn to my
team and say good practice guys good
practice we designed a great world we
design great stuff we learned so you you
can never be ungrateful with life you
can you know whatever life sends you
there's something to be learned from it
so you know I trust the Universe I do
when something doesn't happen I go why I
tried to have a dialogue with myself Why
didn't it happen and and and the more
you swim upstream with the universe the
less you're going to realize where
you're
going